MTV's jackass and its three successful
spin-off movies main stars out of its
cast of amateur stuntmen but that fame
was fleeting for some cast member Bam
Margera lingered on and viva la ban
where he relentlessly pranked and
attacked his family as well as Bam's
unholy union which documented part of an
ill-fated marriage the Margera era of
MTV is long over
but what's the real reason we don't hear
from Bam Margera anymore indie film
interest in 2003 Margera directed
co-wrote and co-starred in the
low-budget haggard a comedy starring
many members of the Jackass collective
which was loosely based on Brian Dunn's
real-life relationships look what she's
doing you I want to know what'll make
you feel better right now
in 2007 Margera began filming the sequel
Ming hags combined the two films cost
just over a million dollars and were
released directly to DVD also straight
to DVD in 2008 Margera's Holiday comedy
bam margera presents where the [ __ ] is
Santa even though the film's earned
mixed reviews they weren't enough to
secure Margera's acting legacy the note
running a bar restaurant or concert
venue isn't easy but in 2008 Margera
opened the note in his hometown of
Westchester Pennsylvania it took two
years to open during which time Margera
fought numerous community objections to
the club due in part to his reputation
the bar had to agree to plenty of
concessions just to open and was also
forced to hire extra security personnel
basically I've spent about 40 grand a
year it just in bar tabs and other
people's bars in Westchester so I
figured I'd probably save money if I
just opened up my own place while
Margera remained a partner enough and
spent time there
a 2010 incident at the club cost in the
distance in soften location a
neighborhood resident named Elizabeth
Rae went to the club one night to
complain about the noise she claims
Marjorie was not only dismissive of her
complaints but made hostile racist
remarks that's when Ray went home
grabbed a baseball bat and returned to
the club to beat Margera with it Margera
was treated overnight in the local
hospitals intensive care unit for head
injuries had his head stapled to closed
and Ray was arrested on assault and
reckless endangerment charges it wasn't
the first time Ray had fought Margera
reporting TMZ
maybe she threatened to kill me twice
about two please and what she threatened
to kill Missy my wife for no reason and
then she threatened to burn the place
down and then eventually club operations
fell to co-owner Don Moore who closed it
down to 2014 because he got tired of the
long hours marriage problems on Viva La
Bam Margera was often seen with his
fiancee Jen Revell but the couple split
up in 2005 a year later Margera filed a
restraining order against her after she
allegedly broke into his house in 2006
he proposed to his childhood friend
Missy Rothstein the events leading up to
their wedding became the subject of
Bam's unholy union and while the couple
did get married it didn't last
despite counselling Margera's alcoholism
ultimately destroyed his marriage and
their divorce was finalized in 2012
BAM moved on and in 2013 he married
again
this time to artist Nicole Boyd riding
and hosting Margera made the leap to
being an author of a sort with 2009
serious as dog dirt which is essentially
a collection of his drawings personal
photos and random thoughts bands weren't
all impressed unfortunately as one
disgruntled customer wrote quote it's
like when Don Vito talks you can't
really understand him that's how Bam's
handwriting was in 2014 Margera returned
to television to host a TBS series
called Bam's badass game show which
invited contestants to complete
toned-down stunts similar to the ones on
jackass for the chance to win $100,000
it was cancelled after just six episodes
due to poor ratings and the misfortune
of running against WWE shows and the NBA
playoffs coming significantly into
Margera's fan base stop the music
in 2002 BAM started a band called narc
Hill with his brother Jes Margera of CKY
and brandon dicamillo of jackass Margera
essentially created the band as an
outlet for as he put it getting drunk
and recording songs on his tape recorder
they released two albums before
splitting up his subsequent fan base
unstoppable also fell apart quickly with
guitarist Chad Ginsberg quitting the
band because he had a hard time watching
bands alcoholism grow worse following
the death of Jackass co-star Ryan
in 2014 a face unstoppable tour was
canceled after just three days Margera
also hosted a weekly show titled radio
BAM on sirius satellite radio but after
nearly a decade on the dial the show
quietly disappeared from the services
lineup in early 2013 knocked out cold
in June 2015 Margera was booked to play
the secret solstice festival in
Reykjavik Iceland afterward Margera
allegedly got drunk and tried to force
his way into the control room two female
security guards tried to block him from
getting in triggering a skirmish
unfortunately for BAM the Atlantic rap
group blazer mafia was nearby Oh noticed
the scuffle the rapper's intervened a
gamer Jerris such a beat-down that he
was knocked out family therapy in 2015
Margera and his mother aprile appeared
on vh1's family therapy with dr. Jenn
after the incident in Iceland April
Margera realized something had to be
done
and she contacted the producers of
family therapy to stage an intervention
during that BAM was going to die a far
cry from the relationship depicted on
Viva La Bam the show reportedly led to
Bam sobering-up giving up booze cold
turkey earth rocker in 2015 Margera
announced that he was transitioning from
reality TV to it's brainy or cousin
documentary filmmaking he released a
trailer for a film he claimed to have
been working on for three years called I
need time to stay useless about his
journey from poverty to jackass Fame and
how he dealt with Dunn's death Margera
also planned to include dreamlike
scripted sequences about done to be
portrayed by methadone guitarist Brent
Hinds as of 2016 the movie retitled
earth rocker has yet to be released
outside of a handful of test screenings
I don't go out anymore cuz I hate every
character
for years I wasted sipping on drinks at
the bar chitchat with nobodies now I
stay at home like a hermit hopefully it
will come out before too long and we'll
all be seeing people of BAM again soon
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
that the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know your favorite Bam
Margera moment